This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In 1906, the journalist Upton Sinclair published The Jungle, a novel based on his undercover reporting in Chicago's meatpacking plants. The book tells a story of a young couple, Yorgis and Ona, who immigrate to the U.S. from Lithuania along with their relatives. The optimism they feel about their new country is soon tested. Family members find jobs at a meatpacking plant, but the work is dangerous and pays little.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。1906年，记者厄普顿·辛克莱出版了小说《屠场》，该书基于他在芝加哥肉类加工厂的卧底调查。书里讲述了一对年轻夫妇——尤吉斯和奥娜，他们与亲戚一起从立陶宛移民到美国。他们对这个新国家怀有的乐观情绪很快就受到了考验。家庭成员在肉类加工厂找到了工作，但工作既危险，报酬又微薄。
The family suffers illness and injuries. Work is tenuous, with periodic wage cuts, poor benefits, and seasonal layoffs. The family is evicted from their home and moves to a crowded, dirty boarding house. Unable to afford a doctor, Ona dies in childbirth, as does her baby. When Jorgis and Ona's remaining son dies as well, Jorgis slides into alcoholism. Optin Sinclair wrote The Jungle with the aim of awakening the conscience of Americans to the desperate conditions of the working poor. He hoped to spark a movement
这个家庭饱受疾病和伤痛的折磨。工作极不稳定，伴随着定期的减薪、微薄的福利和季节性裁员。他们被赶出了家门，搬进了一间拥挤、肮脏的寄宿公寓。由于付不起医药费，奥娜在分娩时去世，她的孩子也随之夭折。当尤吉斯和奥娜剩下的儿子也去世后，尤吉斯陷入了酗酒。厄普顿·辛克莱写《屠场》的目的是唤醒美国人对贫困劳动者绝望处境的良知。他希望引发一场运动，
that would reform the nation's labor laws, but the public did not respond the way he expected. Readers did care about the quality of the meat they ate, but seemed indifferent to the plight of exploited workers. Journalists, activists, and leaders often get frustrated when their best effort to draw attention to a cause does not prompt people to get off their couches and take action. Sometimes, this is because people feel apathetic. They don't know how to respond
一场能够改革国家劳动法的运动，但公众的反应并没有如他所愿。读者确实关心他们所吃肉类的质量，但似乎对被剥削工人的困境漠不关心。当记者、活动家和领导者们为引起对某项事业的关注而付出的最大努力，却无法促使人们从沙发上站起来采取行动时，他们往往会感到沮丧。有时，这是因为人们感到冷漠。他们不知道该如何回应，
or assume any efforts they make will go nowhere. Other times it's because they feel overwhelmed or consumed with paralyzing guilt. Whatever the driver, when it comes to existential issues such as climate change or war, inaction can have terrible consequences. This week on Hidden Brain, we continue our New Year's series, Wellness 2.0. We look at how we come to feel disengaged and burned out, even on topics we might care about, and how we can begin to retrieve our sense of efficacy and purpose. Many problems we face are easy to solve. A missing ingredient for a recipe, a burned out light bulb, a parking ticket.
或者认为他们所做的任何努力都无济于事。另一些时候，这是因为他们感到不知所措，或者被瘫痪性的内疚感所吞噬。无论驱动因素是什么，当涉及到气候变化或战争等生存问题时，不作为可能会带来可怕的后果。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们继续我们的新年系列节目“健康2.0”。我们将探讨我们是如何感到脱节和精疲力竭的，即使是在我们可能关心的话题上，以及我们如何开始找回我们的效能感和目标感。我们面临的许多问题都很容易解决。食谱里缺了一种配料、灯泡烧坏了、一张停车罚单。
We make short work of these problems, briskly crossing them off our to-do lists. But modern life also seems full of issues that researchers call wicked problems, challenges so huge, complicated and intractable that they defy our attempts to solve them. When we come up against problems like these, we tend to respond differently. At California State Polytechnic University Humboldt, Sarah Jackett-Ray studies how we respond to huge, overwhelming problems and how we can get better at dealing with them. Sarah Jackett-Ray, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much.
我们很快就能解决这些问题，利落地把它们从待办事项清单上划掉。但现代生活似乎也充满了研究人员所说的“棘手问题”，这些挑战如此巨大、复杂且难以处理，以至于它们无视我们解决它们的尝试。当我们遇到这类问题时，我们往往会做出不同的反应。在加州州立理工大学洪堡分校，莎拉·杰克特-雷研究我们如何应对巨大、压倒性的问题，以及我们如何能更好地处理它们。莎拉·杰克特-雷，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢。
So nice to be here, Shankar. Sarah, a lot of your work focuses on the way people respond to the threat of climate change. Many of your students care deeply about the environment. In the course of working with them, you've seen a lot of intense emotions. Can you describe what office hours were like, late night emails from students? Yeah, so I would say about, you know, 15 years ago when I started teaching environmental studies,
很高兴来到这里，尚卡尔。莎拉，你的很多工作都集中在人们如何应对气候变化威胁上。你的许多学生非常关心环境。在与他们共事的过程中，你看到了很多强烈的情绪。你能描述一下办公时间是什么样的，或者学生深夜发来的邮件吗？是的，所以我想说，大约15年前，当我开始教授环境研究时，
it was a little bit of a boutique subject, and people would come in and get the information, how bad things are, figure out how they can do some fixing and carry on with their merry way. About 10 years ago, though, something really seemed to have shifted in my students where they were coming in already pretty informed about how bad things were. And so they would come to my office hours to tell me, oh, that reading or that movie or that thing that you showed in class really pulled the rug out from underneath me in whatever particular way.
那还是一个比较小众的学科，人们会进来获取信息，了解情况有多糟糕，找出他们能做些什么来修复，然后继续过他们快乐的日子。然而，大约10年前，我的学生似乎发生了一些真正的转变，他们进来时已经相当了解情况有多糟糕了。所以他们会来我的办公时间告诉我，哦，你课上展示的那篇阅读材料、那部电影或那件事，真的以某种特定的方式彻底击垮了我。
It showed me how complicit I am in the problem or how bad the future's gonna look. And it got overwhelming for me. I couldn't contain it in my class or even in office hours. A few years ago, your students felt a powerful connection to a video that appeared on Facebook. I'm going to play a little audio clip from the video. It features a six-year-old boy who has seen a documentary about how human activity is harming animals. And I just don't want animals to die.
它向我展示了我在这个问题上是多么同谋，或者未来看起来会有多糟糕。这让我感到不知所措。我无法在课堂上，甚至在办公时间里控制住这种情绪。几年前，你的学生对出现在Facebook上的一段视频产生了强烈的共鸣。我要播放一段视频中的音频片段。视频里是一个六岁的男孩，他看过一部关于人类活动如何伤害动物的纪录片。我只是不想让动物死。
I wish I was an adult right now. Why do you wish you were an adult? Because I don't want animals to die! I wish I was an adult right now. Why do you wish you were an adult, honey? I just want to do my job right now! Baby animals, oh my gosh! They eat the garbage and I hate those people who make them do that!
我希望我现在是个成年人。你为什么希望自己是个成年人？因为我不想让动物死！我希望我现在是个成年人。你为什么希望自己是个成年人，亲爱的？我只是想现在就去做我的工作！小动物，天哪！它们吃垃圾，我讨厌那些让它们这样做的那些人！
Can you describe what happens in this viral video, Sarah? Yeah, so this mom seems to be videotaping her son in the backseat in his car seat and he's crying, he's really wailing. And he seems like he may have just learned in a class or somewhere else how much damage humans have done to the planet in the form of killing animals and trash, all kinds of things, paving forests over with cement. And he's really crying and devastated having learned the extent and scope of human impact on the planet. And he wants very much to get out there and fix it and yell at those adults.
你能描述一下这个病毒式传播的视频里发生了什么吗，莎拉？是的，这位妈妈似乎在拍摄坐在后座安全座椅上的儿子，他在哭，他在大声哀嚎。他似乎刚刚在课堂或其他地方了解到人类以杀害动物、制造垃圾、各种各样的事情、用混凝土铺平森林等形式对地球造成了多大的破坏。他真的在哭，在了解到人类对地球影响的程度和范围后感到崩溃。他非常想走出去解决这个问题，并对那些成年人大喊大叫。
to go out there and fix it and yell at those adults. Now this video in some ways went viral, but I understand that on a Facebook page that you manage, some of your students have blamed your classes for similar meltdowns that they have had. And these are college students, not six-year-olds. Yeah, so it started going viral and everyone said, yeah, this feels just like my environmental studies classes. This is what you do to us, Sarah. And so it clarified for me that what was happening with the overwhelming information they were getting was that they were really melting
去走出去解决这个问题，并对那些成年人大喊大叫。现在，这段视频在某种程度上疯传了，但我了解到，在你管理的一个Facebook页面上，你的一些学生把他们经历的类似崩溃归咎于你的课程。而且这些是大学生，不是六岁的孩子。是的，所以它开始疯传，每个人都说，是的，这感觉就像我的环境研究课。莎拉，这就是你对我们做的事。所以这让我明白，他们所获得的大量信息让他们在内心深处真正地崩溃了。
down inside. They may not have been always melting down like that six year old in my classes or even in office hours, although it felt sometimes we were on the border of that. But it was really clear that that's how they were feeling inside. Some of the young people you've encountered, Sarah, feel an overwhelming sense of guilt about their role in spurring climate change and other problems. One was a young woman you call Maddie. How did she respond to what she was learning? Yeah, so this was actually before she had come to college
他们可能并不总是像我课上或办公时间里的那个六岁孩子那样崩溃，尽管有时感觉我们处于崩溃的边缘。但很明显，这就是他们内心的感受。莎拉，你遇到的一些年轻人对他们在推动气候变化和其他问题中所扮演的角色感到一种压倒性的内疚感。其中一位是你称之为麦迪的年轻女性。她对所学到的知识有何反应？是的，这实际上是在她上大学之前，
and she had become very cognizant of all the problems and she was thinking about things like free trade and labor practices, climate change, the transportation of our products we consume, the life cycle of all the products we consume. And she was really deeply engaged in trying to become a more conscientious consumer. And so when she would go to the store with her family or on her own to just maybe get some deodorant or the essentials of life, much less food to eat, she would look at the product and think of all of the damage that this product has caused in the world.
她已经非常清楚所有的问题，她正在思考自由贸易、劳工实践、气候变化、我们消费产品的运输、我们消费的所有产品的生命周期等问题。她非常投入地试图成为一个更有良知的消费者。所以当她和家人一起去商店，或者自己去买除臭剂或生活必需品，更不用说食物时，她会看着产品，想到这个产品在世界上造成的所有损害。
Every ounce of consumption is some sort of impact. You could calculate your ecological footprint by the stuff that you consume. And when, you know, young people are often getting this activity in their classes and environmental science classes in high school or such, called the ecological footprint activity, where their teachers are asking them to calculate how many worlds would be required for them to keep up with their consumer lifestyles. And it causes young people to sort of tailspin in guilt and complicity and how much just their normal lives cost the earth. And she just couldn't bring herself to purchase the thing and participate in all of that harm.
每一盎司的消费都是某种影响。你可以通过你消费的东西来计算你的生态足迹。当年轻人经常在高中环境科学课等课程中进行这种活动时，被称为“生态足迹活动”，老师要求他们计算他们需要多少个地球才能维持他们的消费生活方式。这导致年轻人陷入内疚和同谋的漩涡，以及他们正常的生活对地球造成了多大的代价。她只是无法让自己去购买这些东西，并参与到所有这些伤害中。
and participate in all of that harm. And so it went as far as making her think she would just erase herself and her body as a way of not having impact and of being more acceptable ethically on the planet. Some of Sarah's students said they didn't want to have children themselves. Every additional person was a burden on the planet. If humans were the cause of so much harm, did you really need more of them?
并参与到所有这些伤害中。所以这甚至让她想到她会抹去自己和她的身体，作为一种不产生影响并能在地球上更符合道德要求的方式。莎拉的一些学生说他们自己不想生孩子。每多一个人都是地球的负担。如果人类是造成这么多伤害的原因，你真的需要更多的人吗？
Other students, Sarah says, fell into depression. Yeah, I actually call it eco-nyalism because I started to see not only my students not show up to class, they'd go into pretty severe depressions where they weren't even leaving their rooms. And we hear a lot about young people's mental health crisis, but very few people who are talking about the mental health crisis of young people are saying maybe there's something to do with the climate crisis, maybe there's something to do with the feeling of huge amounts of uncertainty that they face in their adult lives, and they're not looking forward to their futures.
莎拉说，其他学生陷入了抑郁。是的，我实际上称之为“生态虚无主义”，因为我开始看到不仅是我的学生不来上课，他们还陷入了相当严重的抑郁，甚至不出房门。我们听到了很多关于年轻人心理健康危机的信息，但很少有人在谈论年轻人的心理健康危机时说，也许这与气候危机有关，也许这与他们在成年生活中面临的巨大不确定感有关，他们对未来并不抱有期待。
So, yeah, I think that there's about there's that complicity factor, the guilt. I don't want to have an impact. I want to refrain from my negative impact on the planet and this kind of shame for being a human at all that humanity is inherently just terrible for the planet and doing terrible things. And so yeah, just wanting to not be around anymore is it seems like the logical result for a lot of these people. And it's not just college students.
所以，是的，我认为存在那种同谋因素，那种内疚感。我不想产生影响。我想克制自己对地球的负面影响，以及这种作为人类本身而感到的羞耻感，即人类本质上对地球来说就是可怕的，正在做可怕的事情。所以，是的，仅仅是不想再存在了，对很多人来说似乎是逻辑上的结果。而且这不仅仅是大学生。
In 2018, a climate activist named David Buckle took this attitude to its most dramatic extreme. What did he do, Sarah? Yeah, so he actually felt so terrible about the climate crisis, and he had been a lawyer for a long time doing litigation around oil companies and trying to fix climate change from the legal perspective. And he had come across so many hurdles and so many walls that he became very, very despairing about the options and pathways for addressing the problem,
2018年，一位名叫大卫·巴克尔的气候活动家将这种态度推向了最戏剧性的极端。他做了什么，莎拉？是的，他实际上对气候危机感到非常糟糕，他长期以来一直是一名律师，围绕石油公司进行诉讼，并试图从法律角度解决气候变化问题。他遇到了太多的障碍和太多的墙，以至于他对解决这个问题的选择和途径感到非常、非常绝望，
given our current system. With the tools that we have, we can't fix this problem, is, I think, what he ultimately concluded. And he set himself on fire and immolated himself, leaving a suicide note that said something to the effect of, I'm doing to myself what humanity is doing to the planet. I wanna illustrate in my immolation, our dependence on fossil fuels is killing us. And when Bruce also in 2022 did the same thing.
考虑到我们目前的系统。我认为他最终得出的结论是：利用我们现有的工具，我们无法解决这个问题。于是他自焚了，留下了一封遗书，大意是：我正在对自己做人类正在对地球做的事情。我想通过我的自焚来展示，我们对化石燃料的依赖正在杀死我们。2022年布鲁斯也做了同样的事情。
So we've had sort of multiple of these and I definitely have had students and talked to many people whose children have done this, not immolated but ended their lives because of how despairing they feel about climate change specifically. So you use a term called eco-suicide that I had not heard before.
所以我们已经有了好几起这样的事情，我绝对有学生，也和许多孩子做过这种事的人谈过，不是自焚，而是因为他们对气候变化的绝望感而结束了自己的生命。所以你使用了一个我以前没听过的词，叫“生态自杀”。
Is that actually a term that people are using to describe this kind of anguish? Yes. Yeah. I mean, a climate suicide is, I think, the more common term for it. But yes, it's a sort of nihilistic, logical place to go when you realize that the problem is so big and so bad, and you are so small to fix it, and you are also part of the problem is so big and so bad and you are so small to fix it and you are also part of the problem. When we come back, we probe the psychology of despair and how to fight it. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
这真的是人们用来描述这种痛苦的词吗？是的。我的意思是，“气候自杀”我认为是更常用的词。但是的，当你意识到问题如此巨大、如此糟糕，而你又如此渺小，无法解决它，而且你也是问题的一部分时，这是一种虚无主义的、逻辑上的归宿。问题如此巨大、如此糟糕，而你又如此渺小，无法解决它，而且你也是问题的一部分。回来后，我们将探讨绝望的心理学以及如何对抗它。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At Cal Poly Humboldt, Sarah Jacquet-Ray researches how people deal with complex, large-scale problems. Over the years, she has seen many young people who have heard from an early age about the dangers of environmental destruction internalize the harms that humans have done to the planet. Sarah was initially focused on teaching students about the environment,
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在加州州立理工大学洪堡分校，莎拉·杰克特-雷研究人们如何处理复杂的大规模问题。多年来，她看到许多年轻人从小就听说环境破坏的危险，并将人类对地球造成的伤害内化。莎拉最初专注于向学生传授环境知识，
but over time she realized she was confronting a psychological problem whose effects go well beyond climate change. The emotions triggered in us by big challenges can themselves become an impediment to solving those challenges. Sarah, college students are not the only ones who experience strong emotional responses to big intractable problems. You were chatting some time ago with your 12 year old daughter and talking about the problems confronting the
但随着时间的推移，她意识到她正在面对一个心理问题，其影响远远超出了气候变化。大挑战在我们内心引发的情绪本身可能成为解决这些挑战的障碍。莎拉，大学生并不是唯一对巨大、棘手的问题产生强烈情绪反应的人。你前段时间和你的12岁女儿聊天，谈论着困扰着
world. How did the conversation go and what did your daughter tell you? Yeah, so we were on a walk, and we were, you know, just having a regular conversation about the state of the world, as you do with your 12-year-old. And she was just really dogging on humans. And it felt a little bit like she was parroting what she had heard elsewhere, or maybe
世界的问题。谈话进行得怎么样，你女儿告诉了你什么？是的，我们在散步，我们就像你和12岁孩子聊天那样，进行着关于世界状况的常规谈话。她真的在抨击人类。感觉有点像她在鹦鹉学舌，重复她在别处听到的，或者可能
in her classes or what her friends are talking about. Like it was a cool thing to do to say, oh, humans suck and humans are doing such terrible things. And I thought to myself, she was really absorbing that message from whatever places she was getting that message from, feeling despairing about how humans are hopeless, that there's nothing good humans can do to add to the world. And it made me concerned a little bit about the potential for her own nihilistic tendencies. Yeah. I'm hearing, you know, echoes of misanthropy and sort of self-loathing. And to hear that from a 12-year-old seems scary. Yeah, absolutely. When people's prefrontal cortexes are not developed and they can't figure out gray areas,
在她的课堂上，或者她的朋友们在谈论什么。就像说“哦，人类糟透了，人类正在做如此可怕的事情”是一件很酷的事情。我心想，她真的从她获得这些信息的任何地方吸收了那个信息，对人类是无望的感到绝望，认为人类没有什么好的东西可以为世界增添。这让我对她自己潜在的虚无主义倾向感到有点担忧。是的。我听到了，你知道，厌世和某种自我厌恶的回声。听到一个12岁的孩子这么说似乎很可怕。是的，绝对。当人们的前额叶皮层没有发育，他们无法弄清楚灰色地带时，
they're in this black and white thinking mode, which is also really perpetuated by a lot of the media we consume and the ways that social media algorithms work. You know, we live in these black and whites and I think it's really easy to slip into humanities is terrible and a lot of Environmental teaching also leans on that direction Many of my students take classes where they even the title is called human impacts on the environment National Science Foundation grants will give special grants for people to measure human impacts on the environment with no nuance around what that category of human even means or whether it's all bad or some bad, some good. The stories that we hear about what good that humans can bring to the planet are very limited
他们处于这种非黑即白的思维模式中，这也确实被我们消费的许多媒体和社交媒体算法的工作方式所延续。你知道，我们生活在这些非黑即白中，我认为很容易陷入“人类是可怕的”这种想法，而且很多环境教学也倾向于那个方向。我的许多学生参加的课程，甚至标题就叫“人类对环境的影响”。国家科学基金会的拨款会给那些衡量人类对环境影响的人提供特别拨款，而没有围绕“人类”这个类别到底意味着什么，或者它是全坏还是部分坏、部分好进行任何细微差别分析。我们听到的关于人类能给地球带来什么好处的故事非常有限
and rare. And so there's a huge negativity bias out there on portraying stories about whether humans can do anything good or not and mostly for the most part it's really easy to get pretty misanthropic about what the fate of the possibility of humans doing anything good. Some time ago Sarah you proposed an activity to your students, asking them to visualize what the future held. What was this exercise and how did they respond? I asked them to cast themselves forward about 10 or 15 years and close their eyes and think
且罕见。因此，在描绘关于人类是否能做任何好事的故事方面，存在巨大的负面偏见，而且在很大程度上，很容易对人类做任何好事的命运感到非常厌世。前段时间，莎拉，你向你的学生提出了一个活动，要求他们想象未来会是什么样子。这个练习是什么，他们是如何反应的？我让他们把自己投射到大约10或15年后，闭上眼睛思考
about the sounds, the smells, the sights, all of the things that their body would perceive if they were in a world that they desired. The world that actually had come to manifest all the things that they hoped for. The things that they'd come to college to go fix about the world. Imagine if it all came to pass. What would that world feel like, look like,
声音、气味、景象，如果他们身处一个他们渴望的世界，他们的身体会感知到的所有事物。那个实际上已经实现了他们所希望的所有事物的世界。他们来到大学就是为了去解决世界上的那些问题。想象一下，如果这一切都实现了。那个世界会是什么感觉，看起来像什么，
smell like and sound like? What was the purpose of the exercise, Sarah? What were you trying to do by having them imagine a world where their hopes and dreams came true? What was the purpose behind the exercise? There's all kinds of things that fear prevents us from doing, and I was trying to invite them into a different part of their brain, so to speak, around what they would desire about their futures, so then they could think about what would this be the steps to take to get there? Or maybe even where does that already exist in my life and how can I nurture that and build on that? And what happened was I thought we were all going along just fine and I was in this sort
闻起来像什么，听起来像什么？这个练习的目的是什么，莎拉？你通过让他们想象一个他们的希望和梦想成真的世界，试图做什么？这个练习背后的目的是什么？恐惧阻止我们做各种各样的事情，我试图邀请他们进入他们大脑的不同部分，可以说，围绕他们对未来会有什么渴望，这样他们就可以思考，那么实现这一目标的步骤会是什么？或者甚至这在我的生活中已经存在于哪里，我如何培养它并在此基础上发展？结果是，我以为我们都在顺利进行，我正处于这种
of Zen meditation mode visualizing with them with their eyes all closed and I asked them, okay, slowly open your eyes and come back and share what that world was like, you know, thinking it would be this utopic, cathartic experience for all of us. But they basically said there was, first of all, there was a lot of silence and crickets, and then all of a sudden it was like, Sarah, we couldn't really visualize that future.
禅修模式，闭着眼睛和他们一起想象，我问他们，好吧，慢慢睁开眼睛回来，分享那个世界是什么样的，你知道，以为这对我们所有人来说都会是一种乌托邦式的、宣泄的体验。但他们基本上说，首先，有很多沉默和蟋蟀声，然后突然之间，就像是，莎拉，我们真的无法想象那个未来。
We didn't have any imagination for what it could possibly be. Everything that came up in my mind was dystopic. So you say that hopelessness and despair can also be contagious. So hearing expressions of these emotions can induce similar feelings in others. And you tell the story of a student named Job, who one day had an outburst in your class. Who was Job and what happened? Yeah, so we had been talking a lot about,
我们对它可能是什么样子没有任何想象力。我脑子里出现的一切都是反乌托邦的。所以你说绝望和无望也可能是会传染的。所以听到这些情绪的表达会诱发他人的类似感受。你讲了一个名叫乔布的学生的故事，他有一天在你的课上爆发了。乔布是谁，发生了什么？是的，所以我们一直在谈论，
okay, you all have come in, you're really idealistic. How are we gonna move from idealism through all of these grief emotions, anxiety emotions, anxiety emotions, despair emotions about how bad things are? How do we really sit with how bad things are? And then move into something more like action or some kind of catharsis where we work together, collective efficacy.
好吧，你们都进来了，你们真的很理想主义。我们要如何从悲伤情绪、焦虑情绪、焦虑情绪、关于事情有多糟糕的绝望情绪中走出来？我们如何真正坐下来面对事情有多糟糕？然后进入更像行动的东西，或者某种宣泄，我们一起工作，集体效能。
I had done all this research on what is the emotion that we need the most to do this work for the long haul. And collective efficacy turned out to be the kind of magic, holy grail of the set of emotions. And I was trying to be really explicit about this in the class. And Job just sort of threw it all at the wall at some point and said, this is all pointless. Hope is pointless. There is, you know, this is really bad and nothing you can tell us, Sarah, nothing we can do together is going to change anything.
我做了所有这些研究，关于我们需要什么情绪来长期做这项工作。集体效能被证明是那组情绪中的魔法，圣杯。我试图在课堂上非常明确地表达这一点。而乔布在某个时刻把这一切都扔到了墙上，说，这一切都没有意义。希望是毫无意义的。有，你知道，这真的很糟糕，莎拉，你告诉我们的任何事情，我们一起能做的任何事情都无法改变任何事情。
What was the effect of that outburst on the class, Sarah? It was deadening. Yeah, the students were absolutely dead quiet and really, really felt the despair and wondered if in fact that was true. Yeah, is there no point? There's no hope. And one could argue that there really isn't. How did you yourself respond to this? I understand that you started to feel in some ways the despair that he was experiencing and feeling somewhat burned out yourself. Yeah, he was speaking my truth too.
那次爆发对课堂的影响是什么，莎拉？那是死气沉沉的。是的，学生们绝对死一般的安静，真的，真的感受到了绝望，并怀疑这是否真的是真的。是的，没有意义吗？没有希望。有人可能会说确实没有。你自己是如何回应的？我了解到你开始在某种程度上感受到他所经历的绝望，并且你自己也感到有些精疲力竭。是的，他也在说出我的真相。
Yes, and I thought to myself, I can't lift this group up. I can't do this. This is hopeless. I can't do what I've. I can't do this. This is hopeless. I can't do what I've been put on this planet to do as a teacher. The problems really are the way he described. Like many people in the throes of despair, Sarah looked for quick ways to make herself feel better. Some of these things helped, at least in the throes of despair, Sarah looked for quick ways to make herself feel better.
是的，我心想，我无法提升这个群体。我做不到。这是无望的。我无法做我被。我无法做我被放在这个星球上作为老师要做的事情。问题确实像他描述的那样。像许多处于绝望中的人一样，莎拉寻找快速的方法让自己感觉更好。其中一些事情有帮助，至少在处于绝望中时，莎拉寻找快速的方法让自己感觉更好。
Some of these things helped, at least in the short term. You know, I'm human just like the rest of everybody and when I put a phone in front of my face, it's a very addictive thing. I definitely have been known to buy a few things on Amazon after reading some terrible news because it's right there afterwards on Twitter, Facebook or whatever. So there's a real built in design to have us disavow or find comfort in other forms of consumerism, whether that's alcohol or marijuana or shopping or you know, whatever it is, that kind of distraction is readily available to us in many ways, shapes, and forms. And I'm definitely even still subject to that all the time. Yeah. So, at one point, Sarah, you were talking with a colleague sitting at an old wooden
其中一些事情有帮助，至少在短期内。你知道，我和其他人一样是人类，当我把手机放在脸前时，这是一件非常令人上瘾的事情。在读到一些可怕的新闻后，我绝对买过亚马逊上的几样东西，因为在Twitter、Facebook或任何其他地方，它就在那里。所以有一种真正的内置设计，让我们否认或在其他形式的消费主义中寻找安慰，无论是酒精、大麻还是购物，或者你知道，无论它是什么，那种分心在很多方式、形状和形式上都随时可以为我们所用。而且我绝对仍然一直受此影响。是的。所以，有一次，莎拉，你和一位同事坐在旧木头
picnic table about this feeling of being exhausted and burned out. Can you paint me a picture of this conversation and what came from it? So I was sitting at the picnic table with my colleague Jen Ladino and Jen said to me, why don't you turn all of the things that you're worrying about with your students into your research? That way you could try to help your students solve this problem better. It never dawned on me to think about the role of emotions in thinking about the environment. I'd completely been going down a different path with my research. And so when she said that to me, I thought, well, first of all, that's
野餐桌旁谈论这种精疲力竭和倦怠的感觉。你能为我描绘一下这次谈话的画面以及由此产生的结果吗？所以我正和我的同事詹·拉迪诺坐在野餐桌旁，詹对我说，为什么你不把你和学生担心的所有事情变成你的研究呢？这样你就可以尝试帮助你的学生更好地解决这个问题。我从来没有想到要思考情绪在思考环境中的作用。我的研究完全走了一条不同的道路。所以当她对我那样说时，我想，好吧，首先，那太
fascinating. And secondly, it makes perfect sense. Emotions are the most important thing that we that dictate all decision making. And also, maybe while I'm at it, it might be able to help serve my students and make me more equipped to handle them in the classroom so I don't get so burned out. So in some ways what I'm hearing you say, Sarah, is that when it comes to confronting climate change, the turn that you made in some ways was not just to say we need to talk about climate change, but we need to talk about the feelings
迷人了。其次，这完全说得通。情绪是决定所有决策的最重要的事情。而且，也许在我做这件事的同时，它可能能够帮助服务我的学生，并使我更有能力在课堂上处理他们，这样我就不会那么精疲力竭了。所以从某种程度上说，我听到你说的，莎拉，是当涉及到面对气候变化时，你所做的转变在某种程度上不仅是说我们需要谈论气候变化，而是我们需要谈论
that climate change evokes in us, because those feelings can determine whether we do something about it or do nothing about it. 100%. 100%. I was thinking to myself, my students' despair is making them completely out of commission for the work we want them to do in the world. The work that they're going to find purpose in,
气候变化在我们内心唤起的感觉，因为这些感觉可以决定我们是否对此采取行动，还是什么都不做。百分之百。百分之百。我心想，我学生的绝望使他们完全无法胜任我们希望他们在世界上做的工作。他们会从中找到目标的工作，
that they might even find, gosh, maybe happiness in doing. And that's really a shame. I felt really sad for them. I thought, there's something else going on here. It doesn't have to be like this. And I think psychology and neuroscience and social movements and people who have had despair in the past while they're trying to work
他们甚至可能会发现，天哪，也许在做这件事中找到幸福。这真的很遗憾。我真的为他们感到难过。我想，这里还有别的事情发生。不必非得这样。而且我认为心理学、神经科学、社会运动以及过去在尝试工作时经历过绝望的人
on massive cultural change, probably have some wisdom to share about it. had to spare in the past while they're trying to work on massive cultural change, probably have some wisdom to share about it. So as you started studying our emotional responses to big problems like climate change, you centered on several different ideas. And one of them was our tendency towards what you call busyness. This is exemplified by the story of a young woman you call Gabby. Tell me her story, Sarah.
在进行大规模文化变革时，可能有一些智慧可以分享。在尝试进行大规模文化变革时，可能有一些智慧可以分享。所以当你开始研究我们对气候变化等大问题的各种情绪反应时，你集中在几个不同的想法上。其中之一是我们倾向于你所说的“忙碌”。这由你称之为加比的年轻女性的故事所体现。告诉我们她的故事，莎拉。
Yeah. So Gabby got really hooked into a lot of different facets of activism in the community, on campus. And she really felt like while she was working on the problem, everything was moving in the right direction. But it meant that she could never let herself stop working on the problem. She was super hypervigilant. The problem was so big and she was so small that she would solve her feeling of inefficacy
是的。所以加比真的迷上了社区、校园里各种不同层面的活动。她真的觉得当她在处理这个问题时，一切都在朝着正确的方向发展。但这意味着她永远不能让自己停止处理这个问题。她超级高度警惕。问题太大了，而她太小了，以至于她会解决她的效能感缺失感
by just working really, really hard. And there's that kind of common phrase, I think a lot of activists feel this kind of, if you're not angry, you're not paying attention. This hypervigilance that has to come along with becoming aware of how bad the problems are. And that's a pretty common trope. A lot of people go down that path until they realize something like climate change, unlike
通过只是非常、非常努力地工作。而且有一个常见的短语，我想很多活动家都有这种感觉，即“如果你不生气，你就没有在关注”。这种高度警惕必须伴随着意识到问题有多糟糕。这是一个相当普遍的套路。很多人走那条路，直到他们意识到像气候变化这样的事情，不像
a bill getting passed, is an ongoing kind of long-term, many-generations problem to solve. And if they're going to approach it like a sprint rather than a marathon, they will burn out really quick. And that's what happened to Gabby. But in some ways what I'm hearing from Gabby's story is that any kind of pleasure or rest, in some ways in her mind, was,
法案通过，是一个正在进行的、需要多代人解决的长期问题。如果他们要像短跑而不是马拉松那样对待它，他们会很快精疲力竭。这就是加比发生的事情。但在某种程度上，我从加比的故事中听到的是，任何形式的快乐或休息，在某种程度上在她的脑海里，都是，
I am not serious enough about dealing with the concerns that I have about the world. Exactly, so this kind of performance of being really engaged and really busy, and almost to the point of kind of always displaying your bordering on burnout was a sign that you were committed to the cause as you possibly could be.
我对处理我所担心的世界问题不够认真。完全正确，所以这种表现得非常投入和非常忙碌，几乎到了总是表现出濒临倦怠的地步，是一种你尽可能致力于这项事业的标志。
And Gabby was really determined to make sure that she was extracting every bit of energy out of herself to reverse all of the bad impacts that she had had on the planet. And I think that that pervasive complicity part that we were talking about before, that guilt part that we were talking about with Maddie before, that was driving this kind of feverish desire to undo all the harms that she was doing on the planet. You see at one point, she was making amends for the debt she owed the planet, which of
加比真的决心确保她正在从自己身上榨取每一分能量，以扭转她对地球造成的所有坏影响。而且我认为我们之前谈到的那种普遍的同谋部分，我们之前和麦迪谈到的那种内疚部分，正在驱动这种狂热的愿望，去撤销她在地球上造成的所有伤害。你看，有一次，她正在为她欠地球的债务进行补偿，这当然
course was a bottomless pit of debt. So there was no end to what she owed the planet, which of course was a bottomless pit of debt, so there was no end to what she owed. And you call this combination of shame, guilt, you know, perfectionism and anxiety, the cocktail of doom, which is I think a very powerful way of putting what many of us feel on a daily basis. Yeah, so I think that when you have that guilt, you think to yourself, well, I have to make amends for that.
是一个无底洞的债务。所以她欠地球的东西没有尽头，这当然是一个无底洞的债务，所以她欠的东西没有尽头。你把这种羞耻、内疚、完美主义和焦虑的结合称为“厄运鸡尾酒”，我认为这是一个非常有力的方式来表达我们许多人每天感受到的东西。是的，所以我认为当你有了那种内疚感时，你会想，好吧，我必须为此进行补偿。
I have to go make a more positive impact on the planet than I leave on the planet. And because for any one single individual, that is impossible. It's impossible to overturn all of the problems. A single individual is not going to take all the carbon emissions out of the atmosphere. And that's that the hill to climb there is just way too big for any one person. But because of the way the environmental problems are often framed as up to us as individuals to solve, and we live in a very individualistic culture,
我必须去对地球产生比我留在地球上更积极的影响。而且因为对于任何一个单一的个体来说，这是不可能的。撤销所有问题是不可能的。一个单一的个体不会把所有的碳排放从大气中清除。而且那座山太大了，任何一个人都无法攀登。但由于环境问题通常被框架为由我们个人来解决，而且我们生活在一个非常个人主义的文化中，
then we think that it's up to us individually to solve and that we are solely responsible. We will sort of burn ourselves out trying to undo all the harm that we're doing on the planet. And there's not just a misanthropy there, but there's a real self-loathing that comes around with that too, that doesn't actually help us sustain the kind of stamina that is required to continue in the work. And I can see some people saying not just, you know, I am not entitled to rest, I'm not entitled to pleasure, but also saying, you know,
那么我们认为这取决于我们个人去解决，而且我们负有全部责任。我们会为了撤销我们在地球上造成的所有伤害而精疲力竭。而且那里不仅有厌世，还有一种真正的自我厌恶，这实际上并不能帮助我们维持继续这项工作所需的耐力。而且我可以看到有些人说不仅仅是，你知道，我不配休息，我不配快乐，但也说，你知道，
maybe this thing that I'm doing right now, even if it is for the cause or for something I care about, it is insufficient. And so you could ask yourself, what's the point of sitting in a classroom? What's the point of getting a degree? If the world is on fire, what am I doing studying for this exam?
也许我现在做的这件事，即使它是为了事业或我关心的事情，也是不够的。所以你可以问自己，坐在教室里有什么意义？拿到学位有什么意义？如果世界在燃烧，我学习考试是为了什么？
Exactly, exactly. So not only is every form of pleasure also probably tied to some kind of negative environmental impact, so there's that, but there's this kind of futility, right? And in fact, that is exactly what most people do when we talk about climate deniers, or we talk about people who don't are unwilling to face it and how frustrated we can feel about people who don't want to face a problem. people who don't want to face a problem, it is actually cognitively the most elegant solution to the dissonance that we experience, that many of us experience, between how terrible the problem is and then the life that we live and how it's constantly making the problems worse. That cognitive dissonance makes it very difficult to really face into what we need to do to solve it and much easier to just say I throw my hands up. So we've been talking about some of the responses that people have to huge intractable problems and how these responses can sometimes be you know
完全正确，完全正确。所以不仅每一种形式的快乐也可能与某种负面的环境影响有关，所以有这一点，但还有这种徒劳感，对吧？事实上，当我们谈论气候否认者，或者我们谈论那些不愿面对它的人，以及当我们对那些不想面对问题的人感到多么沮丧时，这正是大多数人所做的。那些不想面对问题的人，这实际上是我们在认知上对我们所经历的失调最优雅的解决方案，我们许多人经历的，在问题有多糟糕和我们所过的生活以及它如何不断使问题变得更糟之间。那种认知失调使得真正面对我们需要做些什么来解决它变得非常困难，而更容易只是说我举手投降。所以我们一直在谈论人们对巨大棘手问题的一些反应，以及这些反应有时如何可能是，你知道，
counterproductive or self sabotaging but but you say that it's a mistake to blame the people who have these reactions. In fact, these emotional responses might be the logical result of the way that problems have been presented to people that in some ways we have taught people to respond in the ways in which they're responding. It's no surprise at all that people feel this way and that they feel despairing about it. And I think it is a mistake to say that it's climate change that causes this stuff in people.
适得其反或自我破坏的，但你说责怪有这些反应的人是一个错误。事实上，这些情绪反应可能是问题被呈现给人们的方式的逻辑结果，在某种程度上，我们已经教导人们以他们正在反应的方式进行反应。人们有这种感觉，并且对此感到绝望，这根本不足为奇。而且我认为说气候变化导致了人们的这些东西是一个错误。
We ought to also think about the way that they're getting that information, that kind of machinery of mediation that happens between the actual problem of climate change itself and the human being receiving that information. There's a whole machine happening there. There is the way that algorithms work on social media. There's the ways that people get their information. There's the fact that we get more media now
我们也应该思考他们获得这些信息的方式，那种在气候变化本身的实际问题和接收该信息的个人之间发生的调解机制。那里发生了一整台机器。有社交媒体上算法工作的方式。有人们获取信息的方式。有这样一个事实，即我们现在获得更多的媒体
in the last 20 years than we've ever gotten from all corners of the globe. It's overwhelming a fire hose of bad stuff. There's a negativity bias of the media, which has gotten worse over the last 20 years. In addition, we're also taught we're just individuals, right? So to go back to this point of individualism, oftentimes that feeling of despair comes from feeling, I'm too small to fix this problem. So in efficacy, this beautiful term that social psychologists use is all about the negative feeling of not being able to solve a whole problem outweighing the positive feeling of being able to solve just a small part of it.
在过去20年里，比我们从全球各个角落获得的都要多。这是一个压倒性的坏东西的消防水带。媒体有一种负面偏见，在过去20年里变得更糟了。此外，我们也被教导我们只是个体，对吧？所以回到个人主义这一点，那种绝望感往往来自于感觉，我太小了，无法解决这个问题。所以效能感缺失，社会心理学家使用的这个美丽的术语，完全是关于无法解决整个问题的负面感觉超过了能够解决一小部分的正面感觉。
And so this negative feeling of I can't fix the whole problem because I'm so small, makes us not even want to solve a little part of it. That's an actual bias in the brain. So all of these kinds of things about how small we are, how we perceive ourselves to be powerless, how big the problem is and therefore we can't tackle it, how there's nobody else around who cares as much as us. And so, you know, there's no point in ever doing it. Those are all things that are about the framing
所以这种“我无法解决整个问题，因为我太小了”的负面感觉，使我们甚至不想解决一小部分。这是大脑中的一个实际偏见。所以所有这些关于我们有多小，我们如何感知自己是无能为力的，问题有多大，因此我们无法处理它，周围没有其他人像我们一样关心，等等的事情。所以，你知道，做它没有任何意义。这些都是关于框架的事情
of the problem and the framing of our agency, and those things can be challenged. I want to look at one of the most important pieces of media in framing the way we think about climate change. I want to play you a clip from Al Gore's 2006 film, An Inconvenient Truth. Our ability to live is what is at stake. So, Sarah, it's been a while since I watched this film. Those sound effects really were something else.
问题和我们代理权的框架，这些事情是可以挑战的。我想看看在框架我们思考气候变化方式方面最重要的媒体片段之一。我想给你播放一段阿尔·戈尔2006年的电影《难以忽视的真相》的片段。我们生存的能力才是利害攸关的。所以，莎拉，我看完这部电影已经有一段时间了。那些音效确实是别具一格。
What was the approach adopted by this film and what was the effect it had on people, including your students? Yeah, I'll never forget when that film came out. It was such a big deal. And for years later, even today, my students will tell me that what got them to care about stuff is that film. I mean, it's still resonating. But the rhetorical strategy of that film was very much to create this litany of problems. It's kind of overwhelmed to shock people into caring. And really Al Gore was saying, nobody's caring, nobody's caring, let's just give them more information.
这部电影采取的方法是什么，它对人们，包括你的学生，产生了什么影响？是的，我永远不会忘记那部电影出来的时候。那是一件大事。多年后，甚至今天，我的学生还会告诉我，让他们关心这些事情的是那部电影。我的意思是，它仍然在产生共鸣。但那部电影的修辞策略很大程度上是创造这一连串的问题。这是一种通过震惊来让人关心的压倒性方式。阿尔·戈尔确实在说，没有人关心，没有人关心，让我们给他们更多信息。
If they know more information and they have all the details of all the ways that it could cause disaster for everybody's lives, then maybe they'll do something about it. And I call that the scare to care technique, right? That is really what most environmental educators use. I mean, if we look at the brain and how fear activates people's reaction,
如果他们知道更多信息，并且他们拥有所有可能导致每个人生活灾难的方式的细节，那么也许他们会对此做些什么。我称之为“恐吓以关心”技术，对吧？这确实是大多数环境教育者所使用的。我的意思是，如果我们观察大脑以及恐惧如何激活人们的反应，
Greta Thunberg famously said she wants people to act like their house is on fire, so that triggering of the fear and the amygdala to respond to such a crisis, that's what Al Gore was trying to do. What's the problem with the approach? So there's certain types of people for whom the fear technique really will shake them into that reality. But what was happening, at least in my classes,
格蕾塔·通贝里曾有名言，她说她希望人们表现得像房子着火了一样，从而触发恐惧和杏仁核来应对这种危机，这就是阿尔·戈尔试图做的事情。这种方法有什么问题吗？对于某些人来说，恐惧技巧确实能让他们清醒地面对现实。但至少在我的课堂上，我一直在思考这个问题，
which is where I was really thinking about, people are already coming in pretty scared. They're already coming in feeling really overwhelmed and powerless. And so if I just give them more and more data about how bad things are, the effect is actually to amplify that inefficacy that they're feeling, because I'm just presenting the problem as too big for them to solve. Because of course, what's happening here is not just that you're telling them that the problem is very big, but that they're reminded at every step of the way that in fact the problem is too big for them, that they can't do anything about it. So you're telling them it's a terrible problem and you're helpless to solve it.
学生们进来时已经感到非常害怕了。他们已经感到非常不知所措和无力。所以，如果我只是给他们提供越来越多关于情况有多糟糕的数据，其效果实际上是放大了他们感到的那种无能为力，因为我只是把问题呈现得让他们无法解决。因为当然，这里发生的事情不仅仅是你告诉他们问题非常大，而是每一步都在提醒他们，事实上这个问题对他们来说太大了，他们对此无能为力。所以你告诉他们这是一个可怕的问题，而你却无力解决它。
Right, and we think that we're getting people more, paying attention more if we present the problem as really, really big, that'll get their attention and maybe they'll finally stop doing what they're doing. But in fact, the scale of the problem being so big is what causes an efficacy, which then turns into less action. For some people, Sarah says, scare tactics don't produce apathy, but what she calls a martyrdom complex.
没错，我们认为如果我们把问题呈现得非常非常大，就能让人们更加关注，也许他们最终会停止他们正在做的事情。但事实上，问题的规模如此之大反而导致了无能感，进而导致行动减少。莎拉说，对于一些人来说，恐吓策略不会产生冷漠，而是产生她所说的“殉道情结”。
That comes from that guilt thing, right? That I'm in eternal debt to the planet and to the world. I'm such a bad person. I've benefited so much from exploitation and extraction and violence. You know, the sort of idea that my presence on the planet is on the backs of so much suffering and so much bad stuff. And so the only logical place I can go for that
这源于那种内疚感，对吧？即我欠地球和世界永远的债。我是一个多么糟糕的人。我从剥削、掠夺和暴力中获益良多。你知道，那种认为我在地球上的存在是建立在如此多的苦难和如此多的坏事之上的想法。所以，我唯一合乎逻辑的去处
is to martyr myself, right? To sacrifice everything I have, to sacrifice my time, my energy, my well-being especially. And that if I'm not actually doing that, that I'm not contributing enough. And so I call them a kind of martyrdom. And I think it's really seductive, especially for young people who are just learning about how their privileges have landed them where they are. Over time, Sarah came to see that there was one emotion she needed to induce in her students. It was in despair, and it was in blind hope, that things would magically get better. What the research is showing us is that the feeling of being in a collective is really an essential part of doing this.
就是自我牺牲，对吧？牺牲我拥有的一切，牺牲我的时间、我的精力，尤其是我的幸福。如果我没有真正做到这一点，我就贡献得不够。所以我称之为一种殉道。我认为这非常有诱惑力，尤其是对于那些刚刚了解到他们的特权如何让他们处于目前地位的年轻人来说。随着时间的推移，莎拉开始意识到她需要引导学生产生一种情绪。那不是绝望，也不是盲目的希望，认为事情会奇迹般地好转。研究向我们表明，身处集体中的感觉确实是完成这项工作的重要组成部分。
We have that famous quote from Bill McKibben when he's asked, what's the one thing I can do to solve this problem? What's one thing? And he says, stop being just I, stop just being you. Start to see yourself in this broader collective. Start to plug into a collective because a collective actually has kind of the effects that are the sum is greater than the parts. And I use the metaphor of the choir, right? When you're in a choir, and you're lots of people singing, and you need to catch your breath,
我们有比尔·麦基本的那句名言，当被问及“我能做些什么来解决这个问题？有什么办法？”时，他说，停止仅仅作为“我”，停止仅仅作为“你”。开始在更广泛的集体中看待自己。开始融入一个集体，因为集体实际上具有一种“整体大于部分之和”的效果。我用了合唱团的比喻，对吧？当你身处合唱团，有很多人在唱歌，你需要喘口气，
or maybe you have a little frog in your throat or something, you can take a moment out and kind of settle your body again, get your voice back, knowing that the rest of the choir is carrying that song. Whereas if you feel like you're the only one singing, there's no space for that, right? And so you just keep singing and you just sing through the suffering of it. And this need for kind of recovering and recuperating and making sure you're resourced so that you can keep getting up in the morning and doing the work you're trying to do, much less go to class and do your homework and, you know, have a thriving life is something that I think a lot of people are starting to come around to.
或者喉咙里有点不舒服，你可以花点时间停下来，让身体平静一下，找回你的声音，因为你知道合唱团的其他成员正在承载着那首歌。而如果你觉得只有你一个人在唱，就没有空间了，对吧？所以你只能继续唱，在痛苦中坚持唱下去。这种恢复、休养以及确保自己有资源，以便每天早上能起床并做你想做的工作，更不用说去上课、做作业、过上充实的生活的需求，我认为很多人开始意识到这一点了。
But I would also say that there's something else to it as well, which is that if they don't actually live the life that they're trying to preserve, then they've already kind of lost the battle. And what I mean by that is, you know, this visualization activity where you're imagining this future where everything's great, there are ways that we can live in that way now. What are the great things about that future? Well, maybe we feel rested, maybe we feel joyful, maybe we're listening to music, maybe we're dancing, maybe we're eating good food, right?
但我还要说，还有另一层含义，那就是如果他们没有真正过上他们试图保护的生活，那么他们就已经输掉了这场战斗。我的意思是，你知道这种可视化活动，你想象一个一切都很美好的未来，我们现在就可以以那种方式生活。那个未来有什么伟大的地方？嗯，也许我们感到休息，也许我们感到快乐，也许我们在听音乐，也许我们在跳舞，也许我们在吃美味的食物，对吧？
These sort of like the qualities of life that we want to save the planet to preserve for ourselves are things that we can have now and to surrender them now with the thought that you can have them later after you've achieved utopia is a way of surrendering it unnecessarily early. So I'd say for most people that awareness that you're part of a collective, that there's a choir there is part of it, but also seeking that out and plugging into collective community. There's some really interesting research that shows that action towards climate change,
我们想要拯救地球以保护我们自己的这些生活品质，是我们现在就可以拥有的。为了实现乌托邦而放弃它们，认为以后再拥有，是一种不必要的过早放弃。所以我认为对大多数人来说，意识到你是集体的一部分，那里有一个合唱团，这是其中的一部分，但也要去寻找并融入集体社区。有一些非常有趣的研究表明，针对气候变化的行动，
in fact, doesn't address climate anxiety. It doesn't alleviate our sense of despair about climate change. That action in a collective is the essential thing. And so there's a sort of misnomer that happens. There's a misunderstanding that if we do some actions, we'll feel better. But in fact, it's the collective part
实际上并不能解决气候焦虑。它不能减轻我们对气候变化的绝望感。集体中的行动才是至关重要的。所以这里存在一种误称。有一种误解，认为如果我们采取一些行动，我们会感觉更好。但事实上，是集体的那一部分
that makes us feel better, and less so the action itself. And so the collective makes us feel efficacious. The collective has that social contingent factor of hope and joy and pleasure. Our brains are designed, we're social creatures. So to do all that stuff, it addresses so many of the other problems that we have. We know from the US Surgeon General, we have this loneliness epidemic and it's really bad for young people. And so what I like to say is that addressing individualism is the core
让我们感觉更好，而不是行动本身。所以集体让我们感到有效能感。集体具有希望、快乐和愉悦的社会偶然因素。我们的大脑是这样设计的，我们是社会性生物。所以做所有这些事情，可以解决我们面临的许多其他问题。我们从美国卫生局局长那里得知，我们有这种孤独流行病，这对年轻人来说真的很糟糕。所以我喜欢说，解决个人主义是核心，
for both our mental health and it's also what the planet needs from us. So that's where collective efficacy comes from. Modern life is full of problems that seem too big for any of us to solve. What can we do? We start to ask. The problem is so big and I am so small. When we come back, how to make our problems smaller and our cells bigger.
既为了我们的心理健康，也是地球对我们的需求。这就是集体效能感的来源。现代生活充满了对我们任何一个人来说似乎都太大的问题。我们能做什么？我们开始问。问题太大了，而我太渺小了。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何让我们的问题变小，让我们的自我变大。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Sarah Jackett-Ray has spent many years studying our emotional responses to big, intractable problems like climate change. Over time, she started to realize that our emotional responses to such problems can be part of the solution or part of the problem. Sarah is the author of a field guide to climate anxiety, How to Keep Your Cool on a Warming Planet. Sarah, can you tell me the story of Chris Jordan? He was a photographer who made multiple trips to the Pacific Ocean to take pictures of birds who were dying from plastic waste that they had
你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。莎拉·杰克特-雷多年来一直在研究我们对气候变化等重大、棘手问题的心理反应。随着时间的推移，她开始意识到我们对这些问题的心理反应可能是解决方案的一部分，也可能是问题的一部分。莎拉是《气候焦虑指南：如何在变暖的星球上保持冷静》一书的作者。莎拉，你能给我讲讲克里斯·乔丹的故事吗？他是一位摄影师，曾多次前往太平洋拍摄那些死于塑料垃圾的鸟类，它们
ingested. Chris Jordan is an artist and he was making a film trying to document the destruction of all the deaths of albatross birds on the Midway Atoll and he made a film about it called Midway and he would go out there and check out the stomachs of these birds and these dead birds all over the atoll, peel them open and take pictures of their bared stomachs with all of this plastic in it. And just from looking at a picture of one of these albatross, you can tell that this albatross died of ingesting all these small plastics. As he describes it, he's looking at these stomachs of the albatross as like looking
吞食了这些垃圾。克里斯·乔丹是一位艺术家，他当时正在制作一部电影，试图记录中途岛环礁上所有信天翁的死亡和毁灭。他制作了一部名为《中途岛》的电影，他会去那里检查这些鸟的胃，环礁上到处都是死鸟，他把它们剖开，拍下它们裸露的胃，里面装满了塑料。仅仅从这些信天翁的照片中，你就能看出这只信天翁是死于吞食了所有这些小塑料片。正如他所描述的那样，他看着信天翁的胃，就像看着
at the mirror of what humanity has done to nature or what our relationship, our fraught relationship with nature is. He went eight times and he finally made the film of it. The first couple of times he went and the way that he felt about it was just sheer horror. He was crying over these albatross bodies. He felt this incredible sense of despair. He had never even seen an albatross before.
人类对自然所做之事的镜子，或者我们与自然之间那种充满矛盾的关系。他去了八次，最终完成了这部电影。前几次他去的时候，他的感受纯粹是恐惧。他为这些信天翁的尸体哭泣。他感到一种难以置信的绝望感。他甚至以前从未见过信天翁。
Very few people ever get to go to Midway. And here was evidence of great human impact happening far, far away from anybody's, any human life at all in the first place. And he felt that if humans could impact the world in such a massive way that where they're not even ever showing up or any presence of human activity, this was really a bad state. So Chris Jordan's story doesn't end with him making these photographs and feeling depressed. He writes about how he goes back over time, over and over again to visit these birds, and over time his emotions start to change. How did they change, Sarah? Yeah, so in the beginning his primary emotion that kind of eclipsed all the other possibilities was this grief and horror. And then over time he started to realize the beauty of the albatross
很少有人能去中途岛。而这里发生的巨大人类影响的证据，距离任何人类生活都非常非常遥远。他觉得，如果人类能在他们甚至从未出现过或没有任何人类活动迹象的地方对世界产生如此巨大的影响，这真是一个糟糕的状态。所以克里斯·乔丹的故事并没有以他拍摄这些照片并感到沮丧而结束。他写道，随着时间的推移，他一次又一次地回到那里探望这些鸟，随着时间的推移，他的情绪开始发生变化。它们是如何变化的，莎拉？是的，起初他主要的情绪是那种掩盖了所有其他可能性的悲伤和恐惧。然后随着时间的推移，他开始意识到信天翁的美丽，
and the beauty of the place and the beauty of these birds and he came to love the birds. So he started to have a better sense of how you can have terrible emotions like horror and grief alongside other kinds of emotions that seem like they can't happen at the same time, like beauty and joy and love. And so recognizing the both and-ness of being able to have deeply have experienced grief and horror and despair about what's happening came right alongside these other emotions like love and beauty and allowed him to access a different set of emotions that was much more sophisticated and that he argues is much more supportive of the kind of long-term work that we need to
以及这个地方的美丽和这些鸟儿的美丽，他开始爱上这些鸟儿。所以他开始更好地理解如何将像恐惧和悲伤这样可怕的情绪，与那些看起来似乎不可能同时存在的其他情绪（如美丽、快乐和爱）结合起来。因此，认识到这种“既……又……”的复杂性，即能够深刻体验到对正在发生的事情的悲伤、恐惧和绝望，同时伴随着爱和美丽等其他情绪，使他能够接触到一套更复杂的情绪，他认为这更能支持我们长期以来需要做的
be doing to protect the planet. to protect the planet. Chris Jordan writes, It wasn't until several trips in that I began to really experience the beauty of these birds as kind of the antidote to the horror. That's been the shape of the journey for me as I slowly found my way to love these creatures
保护地球的工作。保护地球。克里斯·乔丹写道：“直到几次旅行之后，我才开始真正体验到这些鸟儿的美丽，作为对恐惧的一种解药。这就是我旅程的形状，我慢慢地找到了爱这些生物的方法。”
and that's really what my film is about more than anything. Just how amazing and beautiful and magnificent they are. I think the Lace and Albatross is a spiritual being. They are amazing beings and the fact that they have plastic in their stomachs is just a stupid thing. It's not the main event. When I first started, the horror was the main event. Now the horror is just something to deal with amidst the enormous beauty and grace and magnificence of these creatures.
“这确实是我电影的主题，胜过一切。它们是多么令人惊叹、美丽和壮丽。我认为莱桑信天翁是一个灵性存在。它们是了不起的生物，它们胃里有塑料只是一件愚蠢的事情。这不是主要事件。当我刚开始时，恐惧是主要事件。现在，恐惧只是在这些生物巨大的美丽、优雅和壮丽之中需要处理的事情。”
Yes, exactly. And I do think that there's something here that is more sophisticated, what I call in my book, climate wisdom, more sophisticated than the binary emotional language that we have in most dominant American culture, which is either you're feeling really positive feelings or you're feeling really negative feelings or comfortable or uncomfortable, however you want to call them. And you can't have this complexity of both and at any particular moment. And I think what it really calls us to do is to open up the possibility of this much broader complexity that the climate crisis is not just this doom and gloom despair thing. The reason why we have fear, the reason that motivates us to act like our house is on fire, is because there's something that we really love that is under threat. And the love is what can really tap to sustain
是的，完全正确。我确实认为这里有一些更复杂的东西，我在书中称之为“气候智慧”，比我们在大多数主流美国文化中拥有的二元情感语言更复杂，即你要么感到非常积极的情绪，要么感到非常消极的情绪，或者舒适或不舒服，随你怎么称呼它们。你不能在任何特定时刻拥有这种“既……又……”的复杂性。我认为它真正呼吁我们做的是打开这种更广泛复杂性的可能性，即气候危机不仅仅是这种厄运和绝望的事情。我们之所以有恐惧，之所以激励我们表现得像房子着火了一样，是因为有一些我们真正热爱的东西正受到威胁。而爱才是真正能够维持
long-term work. It's not that the grief or the despair or the fear go away, but that they can open a door to helping us tap this much more enriching, resourcing set of emotions as well. I'm struck by the fact that so many of the debates that we have in public settings often involve talking in binaries. You know, so some people say, we should simply celebrate everything that humans have done because we're an amazing species
长期工作的动力。并不是说悲伤、绝望或恐惧消失了，而是它们可以打开一扇门，帮助我们利用这套更丰富、更有资源的各种情绪。我感到震惊的是，我们在公共场合进行的许多辩论往往涉及二元对立的谈话。你知道，有些人说，我们应该简单地庆祝人类所做的一切，因为我们是一个了不起的物种，
and we have developed science and technology and look at the number of people we've lifted out of poverty and the number of you know people we can feed today who we didn't think we could feed 50 years ago and this is a story of success and pride and other people say no look at the destruction that humans have done to the planet and it's irreversible and we're just a terrible species and what I'm hearing you say in some ways is that both those stories at some level are true. Absolutely, I love that description.
我们发展了科学和技术，看看我们让多少人摆脱了贫困，看看今天我们能养活的人数，而50年前我们认为我们无法养活他们，这是一个成功和骄傲的故事；而另一些人说，不，看看人类对地球造成的破坏，这是不可逆转的，我们只是一个糟糕的物种。我在某种程度上听到你所说的是，这两个故事在某种层面上都是真实的。绝对是这样，我喜欢那个描述。
And I think that's where climate discourse, climate storytelling and our psychology really come together. The story that the planet wants us to live in is one where we have efficacy and we can in fact fix this problem. And in fact, the problem is fixable in the time that we are here on the planet. And so there's a sense of living in a story
我认为这就是气候话语、气候叙事和我们的心理真正结合的地方。地球希望我们生活在其中的故事是这样一个故事：我们拥有效能感，我们实际上可以解决这个问题。事实上，这个问题在我们身处地球的这段时间内是可以解决的。所以有一种生活在故事中的感觉，
or choosing a story that activates the most energy from us. Because all those stories are true. It's true that things are worse, it's true that things are better, it is absolutely both and. You say it's important to intentionally cultivate positive emotions as a way to constructively address big problems.
或者选择一个能激活我们最大能量的故事。因为所有这些故事都是真实的。情况变糟是真的，情况变好也是真的，这绝对是“既……又……”的关系。你说有意识地培养积极情绪作为建设性解决大问题的一种方式很重要。
How so, Sarah? Yeah. So, I'm thinking here about the insight that many neuroscientists will tell you, which is that the brain is a pleasure-seeking machine. And so much environmental work and so much environmental knowledge, if you open up the door into that stuff, it doesn't feel very pleasurable. There is requests for us to sacrifice, there's requests for us to deny our pleasure, there's requests for us to give up things, right? Renounce our attachment to fossil fuels, renounce things. And so most people don't want to sign up
怎么说呢，莎拉？是的。我在这里想到许多神经科学家会告诉你的见解，即大脑是一台寻求快乐的机器。太多的环境工作和环境知识，如果你打开那扇门，感觉并不太令人愉快。有要求我们牺牲的请求，有要求我们否认快乐的请求，有要求我们放弃东西的请求，对吧？放弃我们对化石燃料的依赖，放弃某些东西。所以大多数人不想报名
for those kinds of unpleasurable things and self-denial feelings. And I think one of the things that ought to really happen around environmental and climate work is a reframing around all the things that we could gain, all the pleasures we could gain. So using the way our brains are naturally designed to leverage better climate action around the pleasures we'll have, the things that we'll gain,
参加那些不愉快的和自我否认的事情。我认为在环境和气候工作周围真正应该发生的事情之一是围绕我们可以获得的所有东西、我们可以获得的所有快乐进行重构。所以利用我们大脑自然设计的方式，围绕我们将拥有的快乐、我们将获得的东西来利用更好的气候行动，
rather than the things that we'll sacrifice. Some people think about this in terms of thinking about environmentalism as a kind of abundance thing rather than a sacrifice or a scarcity thing. And I think that they're really onto something. I understand that you yourself have taken up gardening recently in ways that you had not before. Yeah, I often think about the kinds of things
而不是我们将牺牲的东西。有些人从将环保主义视为一种丰富的东西而不是牺牲或稀缺的东西的角度来思考这个问题。我认为他们确实抓住了重点。我了解到你最近也开始园艺了，以你以前没有过的方式。是的，我经常思考那些
that you can do on an individual scale, even things like resting and recuperating, all just being sort of irrelevant. I mean, I was a product of that same kind of martyrdom mythology that we were talking about earlier. And I think that one of the things that's come out of all of this research is that I need to make sure there's pleasure in my life. I need to make sure there's pleasure in my life.
你可以在个人层面上做的事情，甚至像休息和休养这样的事情，都显得无关紧要。我的意思是，我是我们之前谈到的那种殉道神话的产物。我认为所有这些研究得出的结论之一是，我需要确保我的生活中存在快乐。我需要确保我的生活中存在快乐。
I need to make sure I'm feeding the stuff that's in my life that I love, that I'm worried climate change is gonna change. So if I make sure that those things are growing, those things are thriving, that is one way to make the problem smaller as well. Right, if the things that I love, I'm nurturing, and I'm making those things bigger and bigger, like a garden metaphor, right? If the things that I love, I'm nurturing and I'm making those things bigger and bigger like a garden metaphor, right? I'm planting, I'm putting fertilizer,
我需要确保我正在滋养我生活中我所爱的东西，我担心气候变化会改变它们。所以如果我确保这些东西在成长，这些东西在茁壮成长，这也是让问题变小的一种方式。对吧，如果我所爱的东西，我正在培育，我正在让这些东西变得越来越大，就像园艺的比喻，对吧？如果我所爱的东西，我正在培育，我正在让这些东西变得越来越大，就像园艺的比喻，对吧？我在种植，我在施肥，
I'm putting the sunlight on the stuff that I love. That is another way to make them resilient to the threats that are going to come around the corner if not already here. And so even so, there's this sort of metaphor of gardening that I love there, but there's also the actual gardening, right? I want to have a relationship with the more than human world. I want to care about it. I want to tend to it. I want to recognize and see and appreciate my relationships with other stuff that's outside
我正在把我所爱的东西放在阳光下。这是让它们能够抵御即将来临的威胁（如果还没有到来）的另一种方式。所以即使如此，这里有一种我喜欢的园艺比喻，但也有实际的园艺，对吧？我想与超越人类的世界建立关系。我想关心它。我想照料它。我想认识、看到并欣赏我与我之外的其他事物之间的关系，
of me and my phone. And so there's a sense of this is a way of trying to get into a little bit more of right relationship in my daily life, in the way I walk around in the world. I say in my classes, we have to save the environment. Well, what's one first step I can take? I can look to the environment that's right in my backyard and I can do something to nurture it. So when we think of really big problems, you know, climate change or war or a genocide
以及我的手机。所以这是一种试图在我的日常生活中，在我行走于世界的方式中，进入一点点正确关系的感觉。我在课堂上说，我们必须拯救环境。嗯，我可以采取的第一步是什么？我可以看看我后院的环境，我可以做点什么来培育它。所以当我们想到非常大的问题时，你知道，气候变化、战争或种族灭绝
or a pandemic, we often feel helpless because we say, the problem is so big, I'm so small. One of the things that you have recommended is that we start to take more pleasure but also pride in the small things that we can do. Can you talk about that idea that in some ways we don't have to solve the entire problem to feel like we're making a difference? Yeah, so there's a couple of things at work here. First of all, we are just one person, and also we are part of many collectives in many communities. That's always true both at the same time. And so this notion that all of our actions of our life, no matter how hard we work, are going to amount to nothing really does change the goalposts to something that's impossible anyway. And so what I'm
或大流行，我们往往感到无助，因为我们说，问题太大了，我太渺小了。你推荐的一件事是，我们开始从我们能做的小事中获得更多的快乐，但也获得更多的自豪感。你能谈谈那个观点吗，即在某种程度上我们不必解决整个问题就能感觉到我们在产生影响？是的，这里有几件事在起作用。首先，我们只是一个人，同时我们也是许多集体和许多社区的一部分。这两者总是同时成立的。所以这种认为我们生活中的所有行动，无论我们多么努力，都将一事无成的观念，确实把目标变成了不可能实现的东西。所以我的
suggesting there is that the small actions that we can do are really all we can do anyway. Even if you had all the power on the planet, you could make very little difference in the climate crisis. And so we really have to figure out what is our motivation for doing these kinds of actions that isn't based on knowing that our actions are going to make the difference we want to see in the world. We have to find some non-instrumentalist approach to why it is that we're doing those actions. And I think that gives us permission to do things that are small, not because we think that they will add up to anything big, but because they themselves inherently are adding
建议是，我们能做的小行动确实是我们唯一能做的。即使你拥有地球上所有的权力，你在气候危机中也只能产生很小的影响。所以我们真的必须弄清楚我们做这些行动的动机是什么，而不是基于知道我们的行动会产生我们想要在世界上看到的变化。我们必须找到某种非工具性的方法来解释为什么我们要进行这些行动。我认为这给了我们做小事的许可，不是因为我们认为它们会加起来变成什么大事，而是因为它们本身就在本质上增加
something positive into the world, and that is a good enough reason to do it in and of itself. The binary thinking that goes into either we're going to have an apocalypse or we're going to have a utopia means that we don't really think that we can do anything unless it's going to give us the utopia means that we don't really think that we can do anything unless it's going to give us the utopia. Sarah says it's easy to see hubris in human actions that damage the planet. But she says people fighting to save the planet can suffer from hubris too. from hubris too. Yes.
了一些积极的东西到世界上，这本身就是一个足够好的理由去做它。那种认为我们要么会迎来末日，要么会迎来乌托邦的二元思维意味着我们并不真正认为我们可以做任何事情，除非它能给我们带来乌托邦。莎拉说，在破坏地球的人类行为中看到傲慢很容易。但她说，为拯救地球而奋斗的人也可能遭受傲慢的困扰。是的。
There's this kind of Western American consumer culture that sort of makes us think that everything is all about us. This personalizing everything, aggrandizing our ego. And I think that there's some sort of beautiful invitation in seeing yourself in a collective that is also about saying, I don't actually matter that much, right? This sort of a counterintuitive, instead of saying, oh, I'm gonna show up in the world and make this big, huge positive impact.
有一种西方美国消费文化，它让我们认为一切都与我们有关。这种个人化一切、夸大我们自我的做法。我认为在集体中看待自己有一种美丽的邀请，这也意味着说，我实际上并没有那么重要，对吧？这是一种反直觉，而不是说，哦，我要出现在世界上并产生巨大的积极影响。
This kind of surrendering of the ego, the surrendering that you can be the savior that saves everything actually gives you permission to not be terribly effective all the time. Gives you permission to find pleasure in the work, gives you permission to rest if you need to, to know and recognize that you are certainly just a small creature in this big wide ocean of other people doing this kind of work who are collectively very important.
这种自我的放弃，放弃你可以成为拯救一切的救世主的想法，实际上给了你许可，让你不必一直表现得非常有效。给了你在工作中寻找快乐的许可，给了你如果需要就休息的许可，去了解并认识到你当然只是这个广阔海洋中做这种工作的一小个生物，而其他人集体起来是非常重要的。
If we attach too much to our achieving in our lifetime, that which we think we should do to save the planet, we will always, always, always feel like we're falling short. And that can be very undermining. In addition, I think that this also invites us to tap into much more kind of humble, grounded, long-term engagement, rather than this kind of, I need to be the savior and if I'm not the savior, then I give up. That's Sarah Jacquet-Ray of Cal Poly Humboldt. After the break, another perspective on how to regain our footing when the world feels like too much. our footing when the world feels like too much. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta.
如果我们太过于执着于在我们的一生中实现我们认为应该做的事情来拯救地球，我们总是、总是、总是会觉得我们做得不够。这可能会非常具有破坏性。此外，我认为这也邀请我们去挖掘更谦逊、更扎实、更长期的参与，而不是这种“我需要成为救世主，如果我不是救世主，那我就放弃”的想法。那是来自洪堡加州理工大学的莎拉·杰克特-雷。休息之后，关于当世界感觉太沉重时如何重新站稳脚跟的另一个视角。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Often when I'm feeling down, I turn to the work of writers I love. I find comfort in favorite poems and wisdom in thinkers who grapple with problems hundreds or even thousands of years ago. Today, as a complement to our conversation with Sarah Jacquet-Ray, we wanted to hear a writer's perspective on how to confront feelings of despair and futility. Pico Iyer brings us this audio essay about a source of refuge he has turned to in difficult moments of his life.
这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。通常当我感到沮丧时，我会转向我喜爱的作家的作品。我在最喜欢的诗歌中找到安慰，在几百甚至几千年前与问题搏斗的思想家身上找到智慧。今天，作为我们与莎拉·杰克特-雷对话的补充，我们想听听一位作家关于如何面对绝望和徒劳感的观点。皮科·艾耶尔为我们带来了这篇音频散文，讲述了他曾在生命中困难时刻转向的避难所。
One day some years ago, I looked around the small temporary apartment I was sharing with my mother I looked around the small, temporary apartment I was sharing with my mother and saw no cause for hope. A wildfire had burnt our house to the ground and reduced every last thing inside it to ash. Every photo, every memento and childhood keepsake, all the handwritten notes that were the basis for my next three books. Everything was gone. I needed to look after my mother as her only child,
多年前的一天，我环顾四周，看着我和母亲合住的小型临时公寓，看不到任何希望的迹象。一场野火烧毁了我们的房子，把里面的最后一件东西都烧成了灰烬。每一张照片、每一件纪念品和童年纪念物，所有作为我接下来三本书基础的手写笔记。一切都没了。作为独生子，我需要照顾我的母亲，
but I also needed to support my Japanese girlfriend and her two small children across the sea. I couldn't work out how to be in two places at the same time. A friend suggested I go to a Benedictine retreat house four hours up the California coast. If nothing else, he said, I'd have my own desk there and a private walled garden with dazzling ocean views, all for just thirty dollars a night. What more did I have to lose, I thought. My future had disappeared overnight and so had my past.
但我还需要支持远在海那边的日本女友和她的两个小孩。我无法解决如何同时身处两个地方的问题。一位朋友建议我去加州海岸以北四小时路程的一家本笃会静修院。他说，至少在那里我有自己的书桌和一个有着耀眼海景的私人围墙花园，每晚只需三十美元。我心想，我还有什么可失去的呢？我的未来在一夜之间消失了，我的过去也是。
On the long drive up, as ever, I heard myself fretting over deadlines, worried about leaving my mother behind, carrying on an argument with a faraway friend. Then I turned onto a one-lane road that snaked up to the top of a mountain. I got out of my car, 1200 feet above the Pacific Ocean, and stepped into a simple cell. Suddenly, in ways I couldn't explain, all the debates and anxieties that had been slicing me up 15 minutes earlier fell away. The sun burned on the water far below. A rabbit was standing on the splintered fence in my garden. I stepped outside and was welcomed by a vast expanse of brush and blue for as far as I could see. I came inside again and began scribbling at the desk, recording everything around me.
在漫长的北上车程中，我一如既往地听到自己在为截止日期发愁，担心把母亲留在身后，与远方的朋友争论。然后我转入了一条蜿蜒上山的单车道。我下了车，在太平洋上方1200英尺处，走进了一个简单的牢房。突然，以我无法解释的方式，15分钟前还在折磨我的所有辩论和焦虑都消失了。太阳在远处的波光粼粼的水面上燃烧。一只兔子站在我花园的破栅栏上。我走到外面，迎接我的是一片广阔的灌木丛和蓝色，一眼望不到边。我再次走进室内，开始在书桌上乱涂乱画，记录下周围的一切。
When I stood up, I had covered three pages, though barely twenty minutes had passed. I walked into the communal kitchen and brought back an apple and some salad. I sat in a rocking chair, munching, and then hours later, after darkness fell, I walked out into a great tumble of stars. Although I was alone in my silent cell, I didn't feel alone. The people I loved felt closer to me than when they were in the same room. I took a long walk at daybreak along the monastery road, past benches here and there looking out to sea, and a smile from a stranger went through me as no sentence ever could.
当我站起来时，我已经写满了三页纸，尽管才过了不到二十分钟。我走进公共厨房，拿回一个苹果和一些沙拉。我坐在摇椅上，咀嚼着，几个小时后，天黑了，我走到外面，看到了一大片星空。虽然我独自一人在安静的牢房里，但我并不感到孤独。我爱的人感觉比他们和我同处一室时更亲近。我在黎明时分沿着修道院的路散步，经过这里和那里看向大海的长椅，一个陌生人的微笑穿透了我，这是任何句子都无法做到的。
Often I just sat in a chair and did what is usually hardest for me, nothing at all. The monks who opened their doors, even to non-Christians like myself, made no demands on any visitor. They were ready to offer counsel if needed, but otherwise they were just working around the clock to ensure that all of us felt at home. When I stepped into the monastery bookstore on my second day, an elderly brother asked how I was doing. I love it, I said. He looked relieved, Clearly, silence wasn't always a blessing.
通常我只是坐在椅子上，做我通常最难做的事情，什么都不做。那些敞开大门，甚至对像我这样的非基督徒也敞开大门的僧侣们，对任何访客都没有要求。如果需要，他们随时准备提供建议，但除此之外，他们只是全天候工作，确保我们所有人都感到宾至如归。当我第二天走进修道院书店时，一位年长的修士问我过得怎么样。“我喜欢这里，”我说。他看起来如释重负，显然，沉默并不总是一种祝福。
Of course, it was liberation to be away from every distraction. But mostly, I felt liberated from little Pico and all his chatter. I was freed of my social self and back in a silent self where I had no need of words or ideas. A lens cap had come off and now I could be filled by the world in all its wild immediacy. In the days that followed I simply read books or wrote letters to friends. I took the same walk again and again. Every morning when I awoke I had no designs upon the day. I let the moment decide whether I'd pick up a postcard or just look out to sea.
当然，远离一切干扰是一种解放。但最重要的是，我感到从“小皮科”和他所有的唠叨中解放了出来。我从社会自我中解脱出来，回到了一个沉默的自我，在那里我不需要言语或想法。镜头盖被取下了，现在我可以被世界以其所有的狂野直接性所填满。在接下来的日子里，我只是读书或给朋友写信。我一次又一次地走同样的路。每天早上醒来，我对这一天都没有任何设计。我让当下决定我是拿起明信片还是只是看向大海。
Over the next few months and years I started going back. For two weeks, for three weeks, sometimes when the 15 retreat rooms were full, staying with the monks in their enclosure. Occasionally I went there when I was jet-lagged and even the silence couldn't help me then. Sometimes I arrived just as the radiance of the Big Sur coastline was shattered by torrential storms. All night I sat in my little trailer on the hill, unable to see another light or sign of human habitation. The wilderness felt merciless and terrifying. terrifying. But even when doubts or shadows arose, I realized I'd much rather confront them in this quiet sanctuary than when I was caught up in rush hour traffic or the cacophony of cable news.
在接下来的几个月和几年里，我开始回去。两周、三周，有时当15个静修室住满时，我就和僧侣们住在他们的围墙里。偶尔我有时差时也会去那里，那时即使是沉默也帮不了我。有时我到达时，大苏尔海岸线的光芒正被倾盆大雨所粉碎。整晚我坐在山上我的小拖车里，看不到另一盏灯或人类居住的迹象。荒野感觉冷酷而可怕。但即使当怀疑或阴影出现时，我也意识到我宁愿在这样一个安静的避难所里面对它们，而不是当我陷入高峰时段的交通或有线电视新闻的喧嚣中时。
When my father was suddenly raced into the hospital, the only thing I could think to do was drive four hours one morning just to sit on a bench along the monastery road for two hours and then drive the four hours back. Isn't it selfish to leave your loved ones behind so you can go and restore yourself?" a kind friend asked me. Not if it's the only way I can learn to be a little less selfish, was my reply. When my daughter, at 13, was diagnosed with stage 3 cancer, I knew that sitting in silence above the blue-green waters for three days was the best way I could find the clarity and calm I would need as soon as I stepped back into her hospital ward.
当我父亲突然被送进医院时，我唯一能想到的就是一天早上开车四个小时，只是为了在修道院的路边长椅上坐两个小时，然后开车四个小时回来。“把你的亲人留在身后去恢复自己，这不是很自私吗？”一位好心的朋友问我。“如果这是我学会少一点自私的唯一方法，那就不是，”我的回答是。当我的女儿13岁被诊断出患有三期癌症时，我知道在蓝绿色的水域上方静坐三天是我能找到清晰和冷静的最好方法，这样我一回到她的病房就能用得上。
I couldn't make Sachi's sickness go away, but I could try to protect her from my own useless worries and resentments. Spending time in silence put a frame around my agitated thoughts and disclose something real that stretched beyond and behind them. To come upon a place that exists outside the realm of constant change makes change a little bit less scary. In all my seven decades, I've never seen so many so close to despair as they are right now. A world is fractured, wars are breaking out on every side. Wildfires, like the one Wars are breaking out on every side. Wildfires, like the one that rewrote my life, tear through every hill. In those circumstances, the simple journey into
我无法让萨奇的病消失，但我可以试着保护她免受我无用的担忧和怨恨的影响。在沉默中度过时光为我焦虑的思想加上了一个框架，并揭示了一些超越它们并存在于它们背后的真实东西。来到一个存在于不断变化领域之外的地方，会让变化变得不那么可怕。在我七十年的生命中，我从未见过像现在这样有这么多人接近绝望。世界是破碎的，战争在四面八方爆发。野火，就像那场重写我生活的野火一样，撕裂了每一座山丘。在这些情况下，简单的旅程进入
silence allows me to step out of the moment and into something more expansive. Not everyone I know can afford to go on retreat, but some liberation is always at hand if only you can sit quietly away from your devices, seek out a temple or church, just take a walk. Years ago, the Trappist monk Thomas Merton observed, When your mind is silent, then the forest suddenly becomes magnificently real. It's hard to get tired of the birdsong above that distant hill. So often it's my mind that makes my problems. It cuts the world up into you and me and complicates the simple. After more than a hundred trips into wide awake silence, I give thanks every time I come back to a reality far bigger than myself. Writer Pico Iyer. He has a new book about monasteries and the role they play in a secular age. It's called A Flame, Learning from silence. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul,
沉默让我走出当下，进入更广阔的东西。并不是我认识的每个人都能负担得起去静修，但如果你能远离你的设备安静地坐着，寻找一座寺庙或教堂，或者只是散步，总能获得一些解放。多年前，特拉普派僧侣托马斯·默顿观察到：“当你的思想沉默时，森林突然变得宏伟而真实。”很难对那座遥远山丘上的鸟鸣感到厌倦。通常是我的思想制造了我的问题。它把世界切分成“你”和“我”，并使简单的事情复杂化。在一百多次进入清醒的沉默之后，我每次回到一个远比我自己宏大的现实时，都会心存感激。作家皮科·艾耶尔。他有一本关于修道院及其在世俗时代所扮演角色的新书。书名叫《火焰，从沉默中学习》。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you have follow-up questions for Sarah Jacquet-Ray about how to persist in the face of daunting challenges, and you're comfortable sharing your question with a Hiddenbrain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, staying engaged. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org.
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果您对莎拉·杰克特-雷关于如何在面对艰巨挑战时坚持下去有后续问题，并且您愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享您的问题，请在您的手机上录制语音备忘录并发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行“保持参与”。那个电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。
If you enjoyed today's episode, please consider joining our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. We're extending our standard seven-day trial period for subscribers on Apple podcasts. Sign up in January, and you'll receive 30 free days to try it out. You can sample Hidden Brain Plus by going to apple.co.uk slash hiddenbrain and clicking
如果您喜欢今天的节目，请考虑加入我们的播客订阅《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。我们正在为 Apple Podcasts 的订阅者延长标准的七天试用期。一月份注册，您将获得 30 天的免费试用期。您可以访问 apple.co.uk/hiddenbrain 并点击
try free. Again, go to apple.co.uk slash hiddenbrain and click try free. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
免费试用，来体验《隐藏的大脑 Plus》。再次访问 apple.co.uk/hiddenbrain 并点击免费试用。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。